OK, so the last lecture we were
talking about competition,
and the result of competition
between organisms.
And I didn't quite finish,
so I just want to finish up on
that lecture,
and then will move on to
predation, an interaction
between two species which
results in increasing the
fitness and one,
and decreasing the fitness in
the other.
But let's just finish up with
competition.
We were talking about character
displacement and beak depths.
And we have shown that when you
have two closely related birds
with the same beak size,
if they live on islands
separate from one another,
they compete for the same food.
But if you live on an island
together, what happens is that
you have this character
displacement where the beak of
what will get bigger and the
beak of the other will get
smaller.
So they can exploit different
food resources.
And this character displacement
is the beginning of species
formation.
And this is very common on
islands.
And these are the famous
finches from the Galapagos
Islands that Darwin first based
his theory of evolution,
or it was an important part of
where he realized that there
must have been an ancestor
finch,
that all of these other finches
that had different
representation on different
islands evolved from through the
slow change in traits that is
selected as a result of
different combination of species
being together or alone in
different islands.
And this is what's called
adaptive radiation.
And this is really a powerful
mechanism for evolution.
This is the Galapagos finches,
but you also see this in an
extreme form in Hawaii among the
honey creepers showing this
incredible diversity of beak
types that have evolved to
exploit different kinds of food.
OK, so before we go on to
predation, I just want to walk
you through an evolutionary
scenario, so that you can see
how this might work on an
island, Archipelago.
So this is the mainland,
and we're going to start with
an ancestor species,
A, and our Archipelago is going
to have three islands.
OK, let me draw this.
Here's the same three islands.
00:03:42<clear/>
So this is time passing.
So as we move,
these are the same three
islands as a function of time
passing, OK?
So at the beginning,
we're going to have our founder
species flying and colonizing
the island.
OK, so A is on this island.
And so, the first thing that
happens is that A evolves and
becomes B.
So each one of these is just
the name of the species,
OK?
This is species A,
species B, through what's known
as the founder effect.
And that is when you have a few
members of the species
colonizing on this island.
You have a tiny gene pool,
and the genetic composition of
this drifts such that it
actually becomes a different
species from the one on the
mainland.
So, A becomes B.
So the full arrow means becomes
B on the islands through the
founder effect.
And now, we're going to have B
migrate to a new island.
So, A is now B on this island,
right?
And B is going to colonize this
island.
And through that same founder
effect, B becomes C.
So let me just write what's
happening here.
B becomes C.
I think you can see what's
happening on one island,
and then it migrates back.
So, let's let C migrate back to
where B is, and C also founds a
new island.
So, we're going to let C
migrate here.
So we end up with C and B here
now able to compete with each
other, C here and C here.
OK, so we've got a new
combination of species,
and we are going to let C
become D here due to the founder
effect, and D is going to
migrate over to this island.
So, C becomes E when with B
because of character
displacement.
So, C becomes E here when it's
with B.
So you end up with E and B on
this island.
D is going to migrate to this
island.
So, we have C and D here.
And, C has evolved to be D
here.
So, we also have C becomes D
when alone.
OK, so this is just a scenario
we are making up.
OK, you can make up any
scenario.
But it's to give you the idea
of how this adaptive radiation
comes about.
So, starting with one single
species on the mainland,
if you have an island
archipelago where species can be
isolated enough from each other
to restrict, but not completely
eliminate, the gene flow you can
have this rapid adaptive
radiation.
So, evolutionary biologists
often study islands in order to
study this phenomenon.
OK, so just to summarize for
competition, interspecific
competition results in
00:09:08<clear/>
either competitive coexistence,
which can be achieved either
through niche differentiation.
Do you remember,
what was an example of that
last time?
The barnacles and the inner
tidal.
One took the high road,
and one took the low road.
That's called niche
differentiation,
or character displacement.
And this can happen very
rapidly.
I hesitate to tell you about
really interesting things that
you don't have to know,
but I will anyway.
This is really interesting
study by a couple at Princeton
of the Galapagos finches.
And they've shown that you can
have character displacement of
the islands over a period of one
or two years,
just depending on the amount of
rainfall.
So, it can happen very rapidly
by just selecting for different
character traits,
or competitive exclusion,
which is the case where the
niche overlap is so great that
one of the species completely
outcompete the other.
The example from last time was
the zebra mussels and Gause's
paramecia in the test tubes
excluding the other.
So, these are really important
ecological and evolutionary
forces.
The other thing I learned from
your comments,
which I was very heartened by,
is that at least one person
really liked the definition of
the niche, of the N-dimensional
hyper volume,
which I have always loved and I
think is fundamentally important
because people throw around
ecological niche in everyday
language and think of it as a
place in the environment.
And I think that a more robust
definition is so much more
useful.
So, let's move onto predation,
which is a very strong
evolutionary force.
It can control population
dynamics.
It can shape community
structure.
We're going to talk about each
of these.
It actually influences
competition, which in turn
shapes community structure.
And it's a powerful
evolutionary agent.
In other words,
it's very important in
influencing naturally selection.
So, let's start with the
classic, here's a classic
predator-prey interaction.
There is two wolves and a moose
being attacked.
The wolves are not evil.
They're just getting their
meal.
OK, this is a very famous
classic study of the snowshoe
hare, and lynx.
Lynx is a cat:
populations in northern Canada.
And these data were collected
by the Hudson Bay Company
trapping records.
So, it's really from the amount
of animals that were actually
trapped that these abundances
come from.
And that's where these coupled
oscillations,
this is the hare,
and this is the lynx showing
these couples oscillations with
a roughly 11 year cycle.
And people spend a lot of time
trying to understand what was
driving that oscillation.
And mathematicians love these
coupled oscillators.
And so, the first attempt to
model this kind of thing was
using a very simple model.
Remember we said the dN/dt
equals rN?
That's our exponential growth
equation.
And we also said before the
dN/dt or that r is equal to the
birthrate (b) minus the death
rate (d).
OK, so grossly oversimplifying
the system, the first set of
equations that were used to try
to describe this,
are if you use for the
predator, you call the predator
dN1/DT equals b1,N1 minus d1,N1.
OK, so that's just this
equation.
And they said,
well, how do we modify this
equation so that the growth rate
of the predator is somehow a
function of the density of the
prey?
Well, the easiest thing to do
is just make it proportional,
right?
So what they do is put N2 in
there.
So, the prey population is
going to be dN2/dt,
and we're going to the same
thing: b2,N2 minus d2,N2,
and the question is how do we
modify the prey growth rate
equation so that it is somehow a
function of the density of the
predator?
So what would you do?
So here, this says the
birthrate of the predator is
influenced.
As prey density increases,
the birthrate of the predator
increases.
How would you modify this
equation so that the predator
density has an effect on it?
It's pretty obvious,
but I'm trying to get you with
me.
Exactly.
It would be the death term.
As the predator numbers
increase, the death term would
go up.
And it turns out that these are
two coupled differential
equations that make a beautiful
oscillatory system,
a couple oscillators,
perfect oscillators like that.
This is predator density.
So that would be N1,
N2, and this is time if you
chart their density with time.
And how many of you have
actually had this in the course?
Yeah, see?
[LAUGHTER]
And what courses have you had
in it?
Differential equations,
yeah.
Mathematicians love it.
But real populations,
predator and prey,
don't really operate this way.
I mean, you see these
oscillations,
but rarely can it be attributed
solely to the interaction
between the predator and the
prey.
There's usually many other
factors.
So, and I'll just give you one
example.
So ecologists go ahead and say,
OK, so what's really going on?
And here's an example.
It turns out that in many
cases, the food supply of the
prey is oscillating.
OK, so the availability of food
to the prey oscillates,
making the prey population
oscillate, which then can drive
an oscillation in the predator
population.
So, it's more than just the
coupling between the two.
There are also an external
oscillators driving both of
them.
And again, I'd like to try to
address the role of
experimentation.
Here is an experiment done with
rabbits.
And I don't know what the
predator was.
It might have been,
I'm not sure the predator was,
but anyway, rabbits,
in which through
experimentation they increased
the food supply to the rabbits
through fertilization.
And they showed that,
so this is the control.
And this is the phase of the
cycle in the hare population
relative to the density in the
controls.
So, showing that when the food
supply was increased,
the oscillation was still
there.
So, it wasn't only relieving
the rabbits of food limitation,
did not eliminate the
oscillation, but if you'd
excluded the predators,
you still also had the
oscillation there.
And if you did both of them,
it increased the amplitude of
the oscillation,
relative to the control.
So the conclusion from this is
that both food supply and the
predation affected the
oscillation.
Another very classic experiment
is the experiment by Huffaker
back when people began to be
enamored of these coupled
differential equations.
People wanted to test the
hypothesis of those equations in
the laboratory.
And they tried to set up
predator-prey systems in the
lab, and see if they can get
them to go in these coupled
oscillations for many cycles.
And Huffaker set up a system of
a predatory mite and a prey
mite.
Ecologists like to use insects
as experimental systems because
they're small and you can do it
in the lab.
And this one lived on oranges.
So it was an herbivorous mite.
And the predator obviously
lived on mites.
And he set up a very simple
system in the lab of oranges,
and introduced the predator and
prey, and inevitably he got
this, where prey would increase,
and then the predator would
increase, and would overshoot,
and the prey would die,
and the predator would die.
So he only got one cycle,
with a simple system could not
get this to persist,
well, that doesn't even qualify
as a cycle.
So he realized,
so this is a simple system.
And he had a grid,
which is shown up here in which
he had oranges.
And he had them interspersed
with rubber balls to have a
little bit of complexity in the
system.
But he found with that design,
he could not get the system to
persist.
So he hypothesized that the
reason it wouldn't persist is
that it's much too simple,
not close enough to nature.
So he introduced all kinds of
complexity.
He increased the size of his
grid relative to the
populations, which would give
the prey mites more of a chance
to get away from the predator.
He put barriers of dispersal,
like Vaseline moats,
and he actually put little
launching pads for the prey.
I don't know what they look
like, diving boards,
I don't know what they were,
but little launching pads that
just increased a lot of
complexity so that it gave the
prey an ability to move around
relative to the predator.
And he was actually able to,
this shows his results over 200
days.
He was actually able to get
three full cycles of the
predator-prey oscillation.
And up here,
it just shows you that they're
sort of a cat and mouse game
going on.
It shows you the location of
the prey mites relative to the
predator mites at these
different points in time of this
cycle, showing that they're
moving around the system,
and that the complexity allowed
this coupled oscillator to
persist.
And of course,
we present this because it was
a classic experiment.
It was a pioneering experiment,
but I mean, there have been a
lot more since then.
And of course,
it has implications for
stability of populations in the
natural world.
As we make the natural world
less and less complex,
it reduces the ability of
populations that are engaged in
these coupled oscillatory
systems to persist.
It increases the likelihood of
extinction.
So this was like a tiny little
localized extinction in his
experimental system.
Another classic example that's
often cited about the role of
predation in regulating
population dynamics has to do
with rubber plantations over
here in Malaysia.
Did I spell that right?
That looks wrong.
Oh well, is that OK?
And I don't have any data for
you.
So this is just a story,
but it's very compelling,
and there is data somewhere but
I don't have a slide.
But, in the first half of the
century, in its rubber
plantations in Malaysia they had
a tremendous diversity of
insects, but didn't have any
real serious problems with
insect pests in the rubber
plantations.
And, in 1950,
they had a small outbreak of
defoliated caterpillars.
And that was right about the
time that DDT was invented and
synthesized, and became
available.
And so, entomologists came down
and sprayed the plantation with
DDT hoping to get rid of this
caterpillar.
In the next year,
the outbreak got bigger.
They sprayed more.
The next year the outbreak got
bigger.
They sprayed more,
and finally the whole thing was
out of control.
And they said what's going on
here?
We are killing these things,
and it's getting bigger.
To make a long story short,
what they were doing,
this is a cocoon.
Oh boy.
How do you spell cocoon?
That's not right.
Is that right?
Anyway, you know what I mean.
Caterpillars live in cocoons,
and there was a,
that's a wasp with a big,
long organ that it lays its
eggs.
It needs some legs,
doesn't it?
OK, I made some front legs too.
There.
OK, so that's a wasp that lays
its eggs in these caterpillar
cocoons, and in doing so,
kills caterpillars.
And what they were doing with
the DDT, is that they were
killing the natural predator of
the wasp.
And the caterpillars
themselves, while they were in
the cocoon, were actually
protected from the DDT.
So the more they put on,
the more they killed the wasp,
and the caterpillars were
released from this controlling
predation, and they had huge
outbreaks.
So, it's another example of in
nature it's really hard,
you can't see what's
controlling what until you
disrupt it.
You have to experiment either
inadvertently or on purpose
because everything is dynamic
and turning over.
But it looks relatively stable.
And that's why this is so hard.
And this is one of my favorite
examples of this,
because it brings together a
lot of concepts that we've been
talking about,
is predation shapes community
structure.
00:28:59<clear/>
And this is another example of
introduced species.
And this is St.
John's Wort,
which was introduced at
California from Europe.
And, it, so I'm going to draw a
couple of habitats here.
This is a forest,
and this is a meadow.
So this is grass,
OK, this is trees.
And these are St.
John's Wort.
So, it could grow equally well
in the meadow and in the forest.
And it was getting out of
control so they introduced a
beetle from Europe that feeds on
St.
John's Wort to try to bring it
in to under control.
And what they found was that
the beetle, because the beetle's
preferred habitat was the meadow
that St.
John's Wort persisted in the
forests but was eliminated from
the meadow.
Now, because the beetle prefers
the sunny habitat of the meadow,
so if you were an ecologist and
you didn't know that this beetle
had been introduced,
you just walked into this
state, you knew nothing about
the history, you wanted to study
the ecological niche of St.
John's Wort,
you would say,
well, I only find it in the
forest.
It must like cooler,
wetter environments because you
wouldn't really know that it was
being controlled by the presence
of this beetle.
So, this is a perfect example.
If we draw the niche or two
dimensions of the ecological
niche of St.
John's Wort,
and we say that just on these
two dimensions that this is the
fundamental niche on the
moisture light gradient,
in the presence of this beetle,
the realized niche is only this
low light, high moisture
environment that you find in the
forest.
OK, so in other words,
to really understand what's
regulating the ecology of a
particular organism,
you have to understand all of
the other organisms that it's
interacting with,
and what their effect is on
this.
And again, that's why it's so
impossible to do this without
some form of experiment,
either manipulative experiments
like I described,
or experiments done in a lab,
or inadvertent experiments by
introducing species.
OK, now let's talk about a
couple of other really classic
experiments that have been done.
And these are experiments that
have illustrated the concept of
keystone predator.
There are some predators and
ecosystems that are what are
called keystones.
And that is if you remove them,
the entire structure of the
community changes.
There are some that if you move
them, it doesn't have a dramatic
effect, but there are certain
ones that are keystone predators
that it does.
And these, of course,
are species that conservation
biologists want to first
identify, and second conserve
above others because there is a
cascade of effects if something
happens to them.
A classic example of this was a
study by Robert Payne many years
ago in the inner tidal
community.
I'm not going to go into the
details of that,
but the rocky inner tidal
community is made up of the
starfish, which is called
pisaster, one of the top
predators.
And there are also limpets,
chitins, if you grew up in
California you know probably
what these are,
mussels.
These are invertebrates-like
barnacles that stick to the
ground, or stick to the rocks,
and also algae that stick to
the rocks.
And Payne hypothesized that the
predator was maintaining this
diversity.
And the way to test that
hypothesis was to put a cage
over everything and eliminate
the predator from certain areas.
At what he showed was that
that's what that ecosystem looks
like if you eliminate the
predator.
You can see here,
here's the algae.
Here are some articles.
This is a new textbook,
see if you get the full story
there, but there's a lot of
diversity of the small
barnacle-like invertebrates.
Then you eliminate the
predator, and the mussels just
completely take over.
And this is preemptive
competition.
They compete with everything
else for space and nothing else
can survive there.
Another example of a keystone
predator is the sea otter,
which keeps the sea urchins in
check in the bottom of the
substrate, and if the sea otter
is not there the sea urchins
takeover and they exclude the
kelp, the entire kelp forests
and all the fishes that lives in
the kelp forests,
and all of the diversity of the
ecosystem relies on the sea
otter's ability to keep the sea
urchin population in check.
OK, so some of the best
evidence for predation as an
evolutionary agent,
or something that's driving the
natural selection of organisms,
are these defenses that have
evolved to avoid predation.
In other words,
if you're constantly under
attack, your fitness will be
increased by features that
reduce your susceptibility to
predation.
So in this case,
there are a lot of experiments.
I'm going to show you a few,
but a picture's worth a
thousand words here.
I'll show you some examples.
Cryptic coloration is when a
prey organism has color features
that make it blend in to the
environment.
So here's a very famous example
that was actually in another
inadvertent experiment.
This is a moth that comes in
two forms.
This is called the melanic
form, which is dark black or
gray, and this is the other form
which is much lighter.
And here it is on a birch tree.
You can see that this one
blends it beautifully,
whereas this one,
if I were a predator looking
for the moth,
I would see this but I wouldn't
see that.
Here's the same two moths on
another tree with darker bark
showing that in this case,
this one would be more fit in
that one would be less fit.
And there's a very famous study
that I don't have time to go
into, but it's a textbook,
that showed experimentally the
relative fitness between these
two forms, depending on the
color of the tree trunks.
And this whole example is
called industrial melanism
because the reason this was
noticed was that in areas of
high industrialization the tree
trunks are darker colored
because of the air pollution.
This is back in England back in
the days when there is a lot
more air pollution.
So, they were able to show a
shift in the frequency of these
two forms as a function of the
amount of pollution and
environment because their
susceptibility to predation was
reduced if this form dominated.
That study is actually rather
controversial now,
so I won't teach you the
details.
But you get the point.
But these moths exist in these
two forms.
Here's another example that's
really convoluted that's in your
textbook.
So I'm not going to write it on
the board.
You can read about it there.
But it's an example of what's
called the evolutionary arms
race.
And it has to do with
Cottonwood trees.
And Cottonwood trees produce a
defense compound that the name
of which is on the next slide:
Soliccorten [SP?].
It doesn't matter what it's
called, it's a toxic compound
that makes the tree distasteful
to predator.
You don't think of predators of
trees.
The beaver is a tree predator.
It chops it down.
So when a beaver chops it down,
a Cottonwood tree,
the Cottonwood tree sprouts new
sprouts.
And the resprouts have much
higher concentrations of this
toxic compound than the parent
tree had.
In other words,
the tree has a mechanism.
And I'm sure we don't
understand that yet,
but someday we'll understand
the genetic underpinnings of
this, the molecular biology of
beaver defenses.
But if it's been felled by a
beaver, it increases the
production of this toxin in the
shoots that come out saying,
OK, fool me once,
but you're not getting to get
me the next time.
It means there's beavers
around.
But the interesting thing is
that these shoots are much more
susceptible to grazing by a leaf
beetle.
In other words,
this increased toxin,
the shoots that have the
increased toxin,
are actually grazed more than
the parent tree by this leaf
beetle.
So scientists went in and said,
you know, what's going on here?
This is weird.
Why make a defense that makes
you more vulnerable to a
different predator?
And what they showed by
experiment was that these leaf
beetles were using that toxin as
a defense against the ants that
want to eat them.
So, they were less susceptible
to predation by ants because
they had taken in the toxin from
the shoots.
So, it's called the
evolutionary arms race between
predator and prey.
In these systems get very
complex.
So here's the data that shows
that, that the control trees,
trees that haven't been felled
by a beaver compared to trees
that have been felled by a
beaver, and resprouted trees
have a much higher concentration
of this toxin.
And this is the larval survival
time of these leaf beetles that
these are from the control trees
versus the browsed trees in the
presence of the ants.
OK, I'm going to skip that one.
That ones in your book,
too, which has an experiment
showing that anti-predation
mechanisms are induced by the
presence of a predator.
So I would encourage you to
look at this in a textbook,
this example.
And then finally I'm just going
to go through a series of
pictures that show all of the
types of defenses that have been
evolved as anti-predation
devices.
They are the obvious ones like
cacti with spikes,
or porcupines with spikes,
octopi with ink defense.
This is a caterpillar that has
evolved to look like a snake,
at least that's the way it
looks to us.
I mean that's a hypothesis,
that the predation on this
would be reduced because it
looks like a predator itself.
These are two different ones
looking like a snake.
And often, snakes have a bright
colored thing on their tail to
draw attention to the tail.
If you're going to be attacked
by a predator,
you'd rather have your tail
attacked than your head.
So, this is a common motif in
nature.
And this is an insect.
This is its head.
And yet, if you're a predator
you'd probably think this was
its head.
And again, whether that's been
established by experiments,
I don't know.
So these are just examples.
Moths often have features that
look like eyes that what tends
to ward off a predator.
This is an interesting story
that is in your readings that
shows that there are just a few
genes that control the phenotype
of this particular butterfly.
I think it's a moth,
between having these spots and
not having the spots.
In the fall,
when it's dry and it's more
selective advantage to look like
a leaf, they look like this.
But at other times,
they're visible anyway so their
selective advantage is to have
these eye spots that make them
look like they have eyes.
OK, I think it's time to quit,
so we'll pick this up next
time, I promise you.
Their wonderful pictures of the
creatures in the deep sea that
are very evil looking predators
that fish with their luminescent
light organs.